welcome to squad ride brought to you by
draftkings live in the bleacher report
app it's week three monday
yes help us pick our week three nfl
squad ride
bet we're two and all so far the season
so thank you to everybody who tuned in
last week
and you guys chose wisely big shout out
to jack vitale who pitched
ezekiel elliott as the week two squad
ride z came through
with a russian touchdown against atlanta
in a wild comeback finish
for the cowboys we asked you on social
this week who
is a lock to score a touchdown in week
three
we picked three of our favorite pitches
to feature on the show we're asking you
to decide the squad ride
and to help you we have our betting
expert
kelly stewart and our everyman who's a
betting man
greg ivor here to give you our hot their
hottest takes
check out the board we have some fire
picks here derek henry against uh
against minnesota kamara versus the
packers metcalf versus the cowboys
etc etc
but whatever the squad rides fate is
ultimately in your hands so whatever you
decide we are riding as a family and
we're all putting some dollars on it
so please choose wisely as a little
special bonus our friends at draftkings
are gonna boost the odds in week three
so we appreciate you so get in the
comments greg's gonna be modern
monitoring them um so drop your locks
and here are and your takes and here are
a few of our favorite takes
from last week
oh hey there bleacher report betting you
probably wonder what i'm doing
but it doesn't matter what i'm doing it
matters what delvin cook is going to do
on sunday yeah
[Applause]
josh jacob i see him getting the first
touchstone
and i see him getting another one
throughout the game it's gotta be dk
metcalf dude is just built
different plain and simple
i love you he went absolutely crazy
[Music]
let's go i am guaranteeing a touchdown
by the cook elvin cook you don't take
that
you're dumb
[Music]
let's go let's go cabbie that just got
me in the giving mood actually
because i'm in the comments giving away
hoodies
and i got the manager who gave me a hot
take he said jerick mckinnon goes off
this week
for 150 scrimmage yards and two plus tds
i like that you're getting a hoodie
because he's on my fantasy team
yes yes now i got another one i'm
hearing
a lot of whispers uh the jets upset the
coats
this is jake the snake look at me jake
that's a hot tank
he really really uh pissed off a lot of
people to have the colts in their
survivor league wow
the jets did you not see them last week
the jets yeah don't buy it we small
sample size
i actually i hope he's right there'd be
like three people including me left in
my survivor league
i got one more hoodie i'm giving away
one more hoodie tabby one more
you're in a generous mood steve 1981
he said jerick mckinnon i'm loving that
pick i do think jerick mckinnon is gonna
have a big day
that's a hot take so steve you're
getting i don't know you can figure it
out if you want hoodies all you have to
do is say nice things about the 49ers
players and greg's just going to give
you a hoodie
i was in a generous mood uh we also
shout out to uh ron jeremy's cousin
there in that montage all right it's
time for our first of three pitches
abe gomez is gonna try to convince you
to follow his lead on our week three
squad ride
remember this the fate is in your hands
abe gomez who you got for us
this week i'm going with jordan reed to
score a touchdown for the niners
and the reason being he caught seven out
of eight targets last week
and a touchdown and nick mullens is
going to be looking for a security
blanket and i think that's going to be
jordan reed this week
all right looking for a touchdown and go
niners baby
let's go niners let's go niners my guy
abe i actually
like this pick with no george kittle
jordan reed is gonna take over as the
niners
te1 option and uh you know how kyle
likes to use those tight ends in that
offense also
let me make a point here there's a guy
by the name of
nick mullen starting for the 49ers now
let me give you guys a little statistics
when george kittle broke the season
receiving yards by a tight end a couple
years ago
guess who was his quarterback nick
mullins
so with that being said i can see my guy
nick slinging that rock today and uh
finding my guy
uh jordan reed for a touchdown
definitely can see it
great great greg listen i know the 49ers
is your team but they're going to be on
the ropes to the new york giants all day
today
i want no part of this game which means
i want no part of this crop bet i really
do agree with you i think jared mckinnon
is going to have himself a day because
kyle shanahan is going to have nick
mullins on a very short leash i don't
think he's going to be letting him throw
the rock around
like he's jimmy g this is a stay away
from me
all the way around first of many hot
takes greg what greg what are the
comments are saying
are there equally as many hot takes or
more in the comment section my guy
jackboy37 jordan read 100
into the end zone you're getting a
hoodie for that
uh here we go here we go penn state
saquon jordan reed for sure getting a
touchdown
guess what you're also getting the
hoodie for that
uh grizz i got one more cabbie one more
for you
grizz1321 i don't know where he came
from with this one
but he threw out hunter renfro
we're gonna give him a hoodie for that
just because we're feeling generous so
okay well gaby mine minus two dollars
greg's not in the comments
next week and not allowed to give out
any more hoodies
we've already given out a hundred and
we're like three minutes into the show
and you know we have actually have more
br betting hoodies
to give away i'm gonna give them away
right now because we have some trivia
for you
and it's an in easy over under format
just right over or under in the comments
and here is the question
did the san francisco 49ers cover over
or under 60 percent of their games
against the spread in 2019
over under 60 of their games against the
spread 2019
simply drop over or under in the
comments g-money's going to pick
somebody
we'll get to that trivia uh in just a
second let's get back to our pitches
we have we're asking you guys to decide
our week 3 squad ride
we have chad bees up next what do you
got for us homie
maybe kill the cam time in new england
this weekend luckily for cam you're not
going against that 2015 orange crush
defense
no no no you're going against the las
vegas raiders
formerly known as the oakland raiders
and that's swiss cheese defense
mark cam down for at least one touchdown
maybe even two with billy b in the
hoodie getting it in
maybe three touchdowns but for sure one
new england rolls
it's superman time for new england down
goes the raiders
yes sir
last week i was on the cam train he had
a little bit more juice though
minus 106. i'm back on the cam train
listen here kelly cabbie if the patriots
are in the five
we know what they're gonna do power left
power right with superman cam like
it's it's a thing we know what they're
gonna do if they're in the if they're
inside the fight
i see cam scoring so uh i like this one
kelly i i like this one
chad's right though i didn't think cam
newton was ever gonna recover from that
2015 broncos defense but as i said
when we did a show to start the season
i'm high on cam this year
i took an outside shot with him to win
mvp thus
i need him to be scoring tds you're
right greg last week
he was plus 200 this week he's minus 106
and that's because the bookmakers
are finally realizing they need to
adjust on our dude cam
give me the odds boosts on cam i like
this one nice
craig are are the commenters riding with
both you guys are they fading you guys
the comments are all over the place
cabbie the comments are all over the
place
but look it i got i got guys in the
comments that wants hoodies so listen
i got matthew boyle saying jonathan
taylor
over 83 rushing yards and he's asking
for a hoodie
guess what matthew boyle i'm giving you
a hoodie
for really for that okay you are really
generous today bro
varun my back cam is scoring more than
one t
guess what varoon i also think cam's
gonna score more than one td too so
guess what you're also getting the
hoodie brother
shout out to roon shout out all right
greg drops the brother at eight o'clock
in the morning
[Applause]
last one last one right here last one
kelly you might like this one go white
sox says
anybody think the broncos could win the
afc
no oh uh
that's going to be a tough one um no
no i i think that well the ravens are
gonna win the afc but we'll get to that
one later
should we give him a hoodie for that no
for just being
brave no no no hoodie whatever you think
greg
no hoodie dope hey we love you
commenters we love you but we're not
i mean greg we got to dial it back a
little bit my dude because it's like we
we're going to run out of hoodies
um but anyway okay so two pitches are in
we have um
abe gomez who pitched jordan reed to
score a touchdown today against the
giants
and then we have chad bees who's got cam
newton to score a touchdown
uh against seattle keep dropping your
hot takes in the comments we have
a few more hoodies to give away if greg
doesn't give away our entire stash so
earlier
in the show i asked did the san
francisco excuse me 49ers
cover over or under 60 of their games
against the spread in 2019.
greg has selected two commenters someone
on the over
someone on the under g-money who do we
have
lined up to potentially win a br betting
hoodie cavs
according to my calculations here um
we have jordan kt
rocking with the over okay and we have
c clinton rocking with the under
all right well the correct answer is
61 of their games they covered in 2019
so it is over
so jordan was that jordan t 1000 what
was that
what was our commenter's name uh
rocking with the over it was my guy
jordan kt
jordan kt you are getting a br betting
hoodie congratulations all right so it's
time for our third and final pitch
g petrillo's gonna try to convince you
to follow him
on our for our week three squad ride
g petrillo what do you got for us
so my week three nfl touchdown lock
is cd lamb the rookie from oklahoma he's
played
phenomenal in his first two games he had
over 100 yards receiving in week two
and he's kind of moved into dak
prescott's number two target behind of
course amari cooper
and i think this week especially he'll
be getting in the end zone because
the cowboys take on the seattle seahawks
and you know
deck press that's gonna have to throw
the ball multiple times i do believe
you will have a touchdown pass to cd
land so definitely make that bet
[Music]
g money what do you think wow cabbie i'm
i'm
i'm just in disbelief that's i i i can't
even get my words right
cd lamb i mean does he not know that
they have a guy named ezekiel elliott in
the backfield that literally have
a tattoo that says feed me on his
stomach not only do they have zeke
they have dak not only do they have dak
and zeke they have amari cooper on the
outside that
i need to score fantasy points today
so uh my guy g petrillo i
i just don't see cd getting in the end
zone today
i mean if this was a little bit more
juice on there i might ride with you but
this just isn't enough for me
yeah this is tough i agree with g listen
cd lamb has paid his dues early on and
you would think
that the dallas cowboys would reward him
in the end zone
but sidi's not the number two guy dalton
schultz is
amari cooper and oh by the way za dak
just took over last week and said fine
i'm gonna score touchdowns on my own
this one's tough i gotta agree with greg
here maybe that three to one i would
take a shot
but i just don't think that the juice is
worth the squeeze here
uh g patrillo uh shout out to your
malcolm gladwell look i i
respect it perhaps it's a halloween
costume for a lot to have halloween this
year greg
what other comments are saying you guys
are both fading this cd land pick are
they
agreeing with you are they going against
you and rocking with g petrillo
the comments are actually riding with cd
my guy k
crump cd all day how about them cowboys
that's a lock for sure
i don't know about it being a lock but
you know what is a lock
you getting a hoodie so congratulations
i love
ranch he said no the cowboys are gonna
choke
they might choke but gets what's not
choking you getting a hoodie sir
so so you're getting a hoodie as well i
got one more cabbie
i got one more one more all right here
we go zach
duffin he says g-money vikes wake up
today
cousins over 250 past yards
thielen with the td book it i saw
kelly talking about the vikings
so uh i'm gonna give you a hoodie
zach just because i heard i got a little
tip from uh some people about the
vikings so
if you guys were watching the show i got
a little tip yeah yeah uh
yeah you're getting a hoodie go ahead
cabbie all right wonderful okay so the
three pitches are in
uh it's time for you guys to decide uh
g-money what was oh yeah the quick recap
abe gomez on jordan reed to score
touchdown chad is on cam newton to score
touchdown and g patroller you just heard
is on cd lim to score touchdown those
are our
three week sorry those are our three
week three squad ride pitches
g-money what's the best one that you
heard
cavs you know which one i like my guy
jordan reed getting into the end zone i
can see
this happening my guy nick sling
mullins is our quarterback today he's
going to throw for over 300 yards i'm
telling you now
take the over on his yard total right
now he's going to throw over 300.
i like him getting the ball to my guy
jordan reed i like a niners win today
so uh let's go baby let's ride it out
let's go
kelly what was the best heard that sorry
what was the best pitch that you learned
i think the best value especially with
the odds moose is going to be on cam
look i like the patriots today i laid
the six with this team
i think in order for them to cover this
game we're gonna need a big
game from cam and that includes him
getting into the end zone
all right so you have all the
information you need to help us
pick our week three squad ride bet drop
your picks in the comments
do you like jordan reed do you like cam
newton do you like cd lamb
draftkings is boosting the odds uh on
whatever you pick so
uh while we tally uh
uh greg
yes yes please give out another hoodie
okay i got you guys cause they are in
the comments and they're just
they're they're all over the place once
again but i got my guy
my guy uh bay legend i gave you a hoodie
last week but he's agreeing with me he's
saying yes greg so
uh i don't know if that's deserving the
hoodie but i i feel the love
my guy bran t gray ii he said he's
rocking with cam
kelly's rocking with cam so since
kelly's rocking with cam and you're
rocco cam you're getting a hoodie
uh here we go atlanta rockstar cc will
be a sleeper pick and fantasy for the
season
once dak gets in the groove
i'd like that take i do need dak to get
in a groove because i have a mari cooper
so just because you said dax needs to
get in the groove
you're gonna get a hoodie i love that
tape are we good cabbie
should i we're good we're good no no
it's time for the big reveal
okay thank you so much uh for holding us
down
um our squad ride votes are in
they've been tallied and in week three
the winning bet
is
cam newton the score touchdown against
the seahawks
oh okay it's at 106.
and uh and thank you to our friends at
draftkings we're going to boost that
from a minus 106
up to a plus 300 up to 10
on this bet so shout out to you guys
check br betting social for a link
to the odds boost and if it hits we're
giving away hoodies
so send your screenshots because we love
seeing the winners out there and
it feels like everybody out everybody
has just got these
fire tickets so keep sending those to us
um
speaking of fire takes and speaking of
winners in 2019
our mvp kelly stewart went 12-5 on her
best bets
so far this year she's wanted one if you
need that action she's got it for you
kelly tell the people you're we three
best bet
all right guys we're going with an ugly
pick i told you guys there's gonna be
some ugly picks this week
so i have a real ugly one for you it is
the denver broncos i got this one at six
it's now down to five and a half i like
that reverse line movement that means
all the tickets are on one side
and the money's on the other so you
gotta respect the sharpness
there now tom brady look we know he's
the goat
but i bet against him in week one i told
you guys this is not the same tom brady
team
this is not the same head coach in bill
belichick tom brady just
four and seven in mile high this place
has not been kind to him
in his career i know in the last two
games he's played there he has got the w
but this altitude this home field
advantage one of those things that
people want to talk about we don't have
this year
is actually the greatest of all
two and a half to three points home
field advantage here now let's look at
what happened last week
the bucks got a late touchdown to cover
that eight now all of a sudden their six
point favorite on the road
why because drew lock is hurt because
cortland sutton's hurt
the math doesn't add up take the points
with the broncos here jeff
driscoll will lead this team to a
victory
hopefully because i sprinkled a little
bit on that money line
get on your draftkings app get that
wager in if you're rocking with our mvp
kelly stewart well done so uh
congratulations to all our winners
thank you to everybody for commenting
the comment section is always
filled with a lot of with great vibes
and a lot of photos
hold on hold on i got one more i got one
okay one more all right
i'm feeling i'm feeling generous my guy
go white socks said i got robbed out of
a hoodie so since you feel rod brother
i'm gonna give you a hoodie i'm sorry
we're we're just making friends kevin
we're just making friends we're just
making friends
i appreciate it we're growing the family
which we this is what we do here
on the squad ride so thank you to um the
three fellas that pitched eight gomez
chad bees
and g petrillo appreciate that keep
sending your uh videos
keep sending videos of your best takes
and your reactions
for a chance to be posted on next week's
show alongside kelly stewart
greg ivory my name is cavi richards
thank you for riding with us
have a great show have a great weekend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you